[music] ahhhhhhh [music]
itadakimasu
[music]
th
tan
[music]
me
more
ni
when oooo
[music]
goo
me
[music] When Kiko
is sleeping  I have to go,
5 people, go
home, I can sleep
already
Kaede-san,
I
'm alive.
Don't contact me next time I'll decide what to do
Eh,
somehow Dracula
[music]
What is the thickness of this letter
Hello, I love you Muska from Oita City
Ah ah
me
How are you doing Sora The
bankruptcy is actually staying in Egypt
I found a very interesting mummy in general
I decided to entrust it to you
hey
This is Mina
[music]
Or rather, it's not Doracilla
points are very cute etc.
I think you'll like the Kita plate too
.  Think about it and get along with me,
get along,
hm,
headache, how can I say
that, all the packages that my father sent me until now
?
Sometimes it's a mummy sent by an old man who's a doll to Mary as an
amulet.  Moa is a mummy sent by her father.
I'm wiping your tears right now, so you can't come.
I don't know if it's safe yet.
I'm starting to feel like I'm not there ah
ah
ah  Let's go back to Egypt
[music]
Already eat Lacus and
go
[music]
oh
That means
I have to put it here because I
have a
lot I think it's hard for you in
terms of size
Okay, okay,
okay, just try it for a little while  Write down the information you know and perform operation 4
If you know the vocal cords, you can rest assured It's
good for an old man to be awfully polite
[Music]
Anyway, I only know that there are three colors def
mirror mirror
Yes
Yeah
[music]
Shih
yeah
Hmm
It's already been sent She's been sent back I'm starting to
feel
pity forcing it back If you're going to do
it, I'm going to pick a name for now I'm
a mummy
[Music] All right, all right, that
hurt
[Music] All right, all right
Ah,
even if I buy a dog and a mummy together, I wonder
if they'll fight Oh, wait for the
report g  What are you eating?
Ah, yes, I'm not jealous anymore [Music] Ah, no more, oh, oh, come on, be
quiet,
ah, ah, Nakanishi, ah, ah, you do
n't have to work so hard that you're
choking, so it's okay.  Come down from here Hey,
Migu [Music] Did you like this name so much?
If
you hold this with both hands and put it in your mouth like this, your face won't get wet
goo
2 Even
more difficult, right away, the
edge is wide  It's going to spill out.
]
Cucumbers
Tomatoes are likely to stain, so do
n't use them.
Let's cut it, ah,
that's a dog,
cucumber skin, net ring,
4 days,
eat apples already
Bach,
marine color in recent years,
apples ok, palms
Teresa's late-night snack
[music]
Mii-kun, you're tired, aren't you
? I came to Japan from Egypt.
It's been a month,
but it wasn't weird this time.
Thank you for shopping with me
4a I bought
more shirataki than that.
It's a mummy, not one c
I can't imagine
that I think the moon will be surprised too The belly and the squishy are completely mummy-like etc.
I'm curious
about the contents
Mikao Mizu
[music]
Okay Ai Matemate Is it because of my house that there are various strange
things? Is it really a mummy?
Hey, I'm troubled because I feel
like that when you say it to Omae. Did you tell Mr. Frog?
Mii-kun, my friend, I love you. Nice to meet you.  Say no,
okay, okay,
fool
Eterna Wait, wait, wait, I
'm sorry Mii-kun, I wonder what happened to
the moon.  And
I'm overflowing with things I want to try
.
I'm going to take a bath, so please take care of Mii-kun in the meantime
Pochi Ah
[Music]
It's going to be a lot of fun Or don't you
go in with Mii-kun Ampe Seriously Mii-
kun, is it really okay?
Well then
[music]
wow
, the car that receives it is
really
funny,
I used to have a bad image of mummies being more honey, but
there are human-moon mountain witches and gods of clothes who like poverty in the world.  Isn't it strange that there are mummies like this
?
It looks sexy It
was
[music]
n It's the first time nani
nanohana
Okay
okay yeah yeah yeah me can me [music] me me 4 a
car
The name of the mummy is Mii-kun.
Length is 12 cm. Girth is 18 cm
.